what happened with that woman
she stopped communicating with me
yeah that was it what what age she has
um
being honestly
it is
[Music]
foreign
my mom wants to know if you like the
woman younger no because I've dated all
ages age is a number for me so I think
it's personality and if you click
numero
I think the Colombia used him for money
because I can't believe she was in love
with him
that's crazy
no
I don't understand something what
in the time you have talking with my mom
yeah you never thank her
one dollar
I don't understand because you spend a
lot of money in your ads girlfriend well
for one I don't have to buy anybody did
you bring her
I did I did
and my mother picked it out okay
I wasn't gonna get a gift but my mom
said hey you have to get her a gift it's
in my room
nice
important
foreign
[Music]